they're
in your yard on your walls in your attic
and there's probably one near you right
now
[Music]
the thought of these creepy crawlers
might make you want to go
on an immediate spider crusade but
with global numbers in the quadrillions
there would be 2.8 million
spiders versus every human
my money is on the spiders
maybe with a large-scale international
effort spiders could be eradicated
just imagine a spider-free world
what would happen to other bugs
would we see an increase in disease
and how would it change the future of
medicine
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we killed all the spiders
[Music]
spiders are prolific there are 45
000 species of spiders that we currently
know of
and scientists estimate that there are
twice that amount that we haven't
discovered yet
they range massively in size too
the samoan moss spider is a mere
0.3 millimeters long while the south
american
goliath bird eater is 30 centimeters
from a nearly invisible one-third of a
pinhead
to the diameter of your dinner plate
each species of spider contains an
average of
500 unique toxins which allow them to
paralyze
kill and liquify their prey
but just how dangerous are they to
humans
well only 12 types of spiders can
actually harm humans
unlike other biting insects they only
bite when they feel threatened
and they don't transmit diseases like
mosquitoes
bed bugs and ticks jerks
some spiders helpfully chow down on
these blood-sucking pests so
we should be thanking them
[Music]
if we killed all spiders we would see a
huge
population surge in these nasty bugs and
the diseases they spread
like malaria zika virus and dengue fever
while birds and bats also eat insects
spiders are the true insect control
extraordinaires
without them creepy crawlers would
flourish
which would be bad news for our food
system
cereal crops like oats wheat corn
rye and potatoes would be the first to
succumb to the horde of uncontrolled
insects
we would have to ramp up pesticide use
quickly
which poses its own threat to humans and
the environment
faced with a declining food supply and
an abundance of insects
you might have to make a diet change
there are 1900 edible bugs on earth and
if we don't want to perish to worldwide
famine
we would have to bring bugs into the
mainstream diet
and it's not just our food source that
would be devastated if we did away with
all spiders
venom and spider silk are being
researched for
innovative medicines and material
at the university of buffalo researchers
are testing the venom of a south
american spider
to treat muscular dystrophy and
venom from the blue mountains funnel web
spider
is being used to help combat malaria
spider silk is incredibly lightweight
and strong
as in 10 times stronger than kevlar
strong
[Music]
this natural silk could be used in
bulletproof vests in the future
if we don't wipe out our spider supplier
first
the same spidey strong material could
revolutionize industries as an
eco-friendly alternative to many highly
processed materials
it's even being developed for use as
artificial ligaments
tendons and surgical thread all of this
innovation would stop if we
slayed the spiders more pressing though
the world as we know it could cease to
exist
while some reports state that in the
absence of spiders
humankind would die out in less than
five years due to food scarcity
other researchers are more skeptical
scientists from the university of basel
claim
spiders hunt more in deep dark forests
and
undisturbed grasslands and not so much
in
agricultural fields additional
scientists believe
nature would simply adapt to fill the
void
with population booms in animals like
bats
birds and lizards
but even if the world didn't end after
we killed all spiders
they still play a huge and important
role in our environment and health
so maybe you should be a little kinder
to the next spider you see
maybe name it charlotte and spin a web
of friendship with it instead
after all it's probably silently
guarding your house from
more troublesome pests like mosquitoes
i for one would rather see a world
without mosquitoes than a world without
spiders
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]